so we got our first look at a post
debate
trump yesterday of course the debate
with joe biden took place tuesday night
it did not go well for donald trump but
to be fair
it might have gone well enough for him
to keep his existing support i don't
think his base will abandon him based on
the outrageous and childish performance
of tuesday night
in fact his base thinks that he won so
it may not really move the needle very
much
but what i was interested in was what is
trump's state of mind what is trump's
demeanor
post debate we saw him tweeting unhinged
things but he did another one of these
corona rallies last night
this one was in duluth minnesota and
trump spent
a bunch of time recently in minnesota
where currently joe biden leads
by more than nine points in recent
polling donald trump has been insisting
he might win minnesota
i doubt it but he's spending some time
there
the rally was really really
sick i i was sort of paying special
attention to what trump would say
about the debate itself whether he'd
scale up his attacks on joe biden to be
even nastier ad hominems
but he also said all sorts of other
things that are of course
untrue and in many cases completely
disgusting so let's look at it a little
bit
donald trump launched directly into
straight up lies by just making things
up whole cloth he said joe biden
is trying to cancel the remaining
debates biden
has not suggested cancelling the
remaining debates
biden has not asked for a cancellation
biden has not dropped out
but donald trump doesn't care he says it
and the crowd believes it
is too weak to lead this country you
know by the laws badly when his
supporters are saying he should cancel
the rest of the debates
now i understand he's cancelling the
debates let's see what happens i think
that's not going to be a good move
i don't think that's going to be a good
move on the television with those
ratings they're never going to let them
cancel you don't know television like
that
this is how nonsense spreads trump tells
a crowd
biden's cancelling debates the crowd
goes goes home and posts on facebook
biden is canceling the debates someone
makes a meme biden is cancelling the
debates and before you know it
there's this false notion spreading that
biden has cancelled the remaining
debates and has backed out completely
untrue
donald trump again told this story that
he's been telling
about how there was a day i i guess it
must have been about a month ago
trump tells the story where he went home
to melania
and he asked darling did you see the
news on tv
about my nobel peace prize nomination
and melania this is the story says to
him no i didn't see it
that they they were talking about a
hurricane and this time
trump adds the really dismissive wrinkle
of saying they were talking about rain
now of course rain was the hurricane
that was devastating florida
destroying people's homes destroying
people's lives and trump says
they covered rain instead of my nobel
peace prize nomination
but i told my first lady i told her
first lady
darling you're going to be so proud of
me tonight we're going to watch
television
and you're not going to believe how big
this goes what happened what happened
darling i won the i was nominated for
the
nobel peace prize for israel right
bahrain united arab emirates
and then again again
i was nominated again for serbia kosovo
all different then i was nominated a
third time but i said first time
second time i was a little bit yeah i
know i love you too
but i said to our first lady watch
this tonight darling it's going to be
and i turned to lester holt number two
show
i turned to lester halt and they covered
one stars about raid
this is just it's the height of
narcissism isn't it
how dare the news cover a hurricane
wreaking havoc
they should be talking about how a
norwegian right winger or was it a
finnish or swedish
some northern european right winger said
i should get the nobel peace prize isn't
that the story
instead of a hurricane destroying
people's lives
the unabashed height of narcissism
donald trump then mocked joe biden
because joe biden takes coronavirus
seriously
and joe biden doesn't want to do events
for his campaign
that risk the spread of coronavirus not
a concern trump has
but trump ridicules joe biden for it i
don't know how many are involved this
was supposed to be an iron range
get-together
but it turns out big you know biden has
20 30 people he's got those circles
today he had a little bit more like 30
or 40 but they were too
close together cinnamon no joe
they were too close 34 people right next
to each other
and yet he complained about our rally
right our rallies
now it's an honor that so many people
showed up because this was going to be a
little quickie just to say
congratulations
because obama closed the iron range
imagine
making fun of the candidate
that's taking the public health
precautions during a global hundred year
pandemic
that you mishandled leading now to 211
000 deaths
far more than what we needed to have
backwards
bizarro world in this next clip donald
trump
tells a completely implausible story
including what we call the sir routine
okay now the sir routine is when trump
tells a story
of someone saying something to him he
will often say
they said to me sir etc
and this time it's about a guy who
supposedly came to trump
so overwhelmed with emotion about how
trump had improved this guy's life
that the guy was crying i mean it's a
completely incredible story take a
listen
a man came up to me a tough man a man
who
a worker a construction worker real
worker
and he looked at me this is two years
ago he said sir
you've given us back our life and he was
crying
and i said when was the last time you
cried he said i can't remember i said
you never cried when you were a little
baby
you never cried this is not a crier this
guy was tough as hell
he said sir he took our our life away
and let me tell you about joe joe will
reinstitute that ban in two
minutes if we lose so you better vote
for him in minnesota really i mean
honestly
imagine being a fly on the wall during
that meeting
between trump and this guy if it even
took place
also this dumb idea that crying is the
opposite of toughness
just every lame trope that trump can't
seem to get away from
and then here we have just a simple lie
donald trump says
he says this in every state every time
he goes to pennsylvania
he goes to north carolina trump will
always say you had your best year last
year
you had your best years during my
presidency and of course he says it to
minnesota here
the story with jason but let's do it
anyway
but we're going to win so much because
minnesota before i came around was not
doing too well
okay was not doing too well then you had
your best years ever
now the truth is a little different the
unemployment rate in minnesota
is now 94 percent higher than when
donald trump took
office the unemployment rate in
minnesota was 3.8 percent
in january of 2017. it is currently 7.4
percent and that's down by the way from
its coronavirus high so
just a simple lie and a simple fact
check how quaint right it's sort of like
the old days of politics
trump continuing to be obsessed with the
suburbs lately donald trump ridiculously
and laughably claims here again
that joe biden will destroy the suburbs
by abolishing single-family zoning
well whether we allow joe biden to kill
the recovery you know he wants a
shutdown this guy says let's shut it
down
a lot of death caused by shutdown
depression
death drugs alcoholism
horrendous family fights horrendous
family face
and he wants to destroy those suburbs by
abolishing
single-family zoning all of these things
are just a horrible thing he
what he wants to do it is stunning how
saying
localities should look at the racial
impact of zoning
became biden wants to end the suburbs
and now its biden will eliminate all
single family zoning
it just just completely disconnected
from reality
and the crowd now because trump has been
repeating it for so long they're used to
it they anticipate it
they cheer or boo or whatever reaction
it is that donald trump wants
and then trump uh continuing with this
suburb
obsession trump admonishes the crowd and
he says how the hell am
i not doing well in the suburbs you know
they talk about
the suburbs women in the suburbs i ended
a regulation
that nobody would have done this brings
public housing low income housing into
the suburbs and by the way just so we
can get this right
30 of the people in the suburbs
are low-income people 30 of the people
in the suburbs are minorities
and so we're ruining this american dream
for everybody but he's got
a plan it's the worst thing you've ever
seen having to do with zoning
they zone you out they build low-income
housing next to your house
it's crazy and then i hear i'm not doing
well in the suburbs
i'm not doing well in the suburbs are
you people crazy
are you crazy that's uh it's an unusual
way
to get the crowd on your side isn't it a
strange way to
to win votes to say what the hell is
wrong with you people
maybe it works for the average trump
supporter i i really don't pretend to
know at this point
what the average trump supporter wants
to hear from donald trump
but the rallies continue and post-debate
trump
as unhinged as ever no rally on today's
calendar for donald trump upcoming
includes next week's
vice presidential debate on wednesday
which we will be broadcasting live on
youtube
twitch and facebook the week after that
is vice is a presidential debate number
two
the week after that is presidential
debate number three
we've got a one-week respite from the
debates
and then it's election day that's it
folks so we've got vp
debate on week one trump debate week two
trump biden debate week three week four
is off
week five is the election and that's it
okay this is the final stretch
later on in the program we are going to
talk about some of the
sort of desperate measures that the
trump campaign is taking
tomorrow we will be talking about
incredible fundraising
by joe biden during the debate record
fundraising
and we will of course have continued
coverage of all of this
and more on the david pakman show
instagram page make sure you're
following us on instagram
one of our sponsors today is
barrymandering a
tabletop strategy game for two players
that simulates gerrymandering
gerrymandering of course is
when you manipulate electoral district
maps to benefit
a certain political party we talk about
it all the time
barrymandering has turned that into a
fun fast-paced game i've been having a
lot of fun playing this
with my girlfriend at home each round
takes about 15 minutes
easy to learn how to play but as i'm
finding out
difficult to master because there are so
many different ways to play
it's a great tool to explain
gerrymandering to someone who's not
familiar with the concept
it's great for two friends who love
politics and want to have
fun with an interesting tabletop game
that is unlike
anything you've ever played before i
know
anybody in my audience would have a
great time with this game and you can
even buy two copies of the game
to make a larger board for bigger games
go to davidpakman.com barry
the link is underneath this video takes
you to their amazon page and use the
code
important pacman2020 at checkout
for one dollar off